ça tourne pas compris qu est-ce que
c'est parce qu'elles sont peut-être cet
univers des canaris comme ça on
retrouvera facilement
oui emmanuel au fait c'est le désert du
kalahari la bienvenue elle chauffe ça
tombait lundi matin sept cars est là et
c'est bien le lundi le désert du
kalahari
alors qu'on pensait la jurade jc
kalahari et mardi c'est aujourd'hui à la
et sap lycée en colis je pensais pas ça
pour toi c'est je reste au lit
je vais vous faire un truc de dingue
attend prévient très bien tu veux faire
quoi et plongée verticale peut-être jeu
compagnie à la vitesse va me s'explique
pique nique à la vitesse que des dicos
doucement en toi voilà et reste en
vertical pour le lit kosovo à ses
geôliers cours de hickory aller jusqu'où
c'est à dire c'est vrai qu'il écrase
12h30 à tourner
en fait dingue oscarisé franchement
c'est dingue
allez on va jusqu'à 10 30
donc emmanuel tu peux avancer jusqu'à 10
ans demain
un basa 26 27 28 ans et variés rêve 30 à
temps
voilà tout est recouvert d'un tout petit
peu ça va repartir alors ils ont
attention voilà repart vers l'horizon
tout doucement tout suspens toute
maniére pam à l'horizon on ne redresse
hockey
ayew